[Music]
on today's show we talked to a husband
whose wife works with his ex-girlfriend
and that's all i'm going to say about
that one we talked to a young woman who
is becoming a trauma counselor she wants
to know how to do that to the best of
her abilities we talked to a new wife
whose husband's going to counseling stay
tuned
[Music]
yo yo what's up
this is john with the dr john delony
show
man i hope you're doing well this
morning it's beautiful outside here in
nashville tennessee
and it is looking good
the world is spun into chaos but it
looks good outside
and i'm hoping by the time we hear this
there's some
better news on the horizon and that um
people coming back together so i'm gonna
keep my
keep my heart to the ground on that one
let's go straight to the phones today
let's go to bill in
central minnesota what's up bill
hey john how's it going i'm good my
brother how are you
uh nervous
hey listen have you ever listened to
this show
about every day okay you know i'm not
very good at this man you're fine you're
fine you will do a better job than me
i'm quite certain um but i appreciate
you calling man it makes my makes my day
that you that you trusted me on this one
so what's up
all right um
i don't know if it's a huge problem per
se or anything but my wife and uh
one of my exes
worked together
and so i'll stop you right there and say
yes that's a big problem
so what is it not really what is it
uh they get along fine um it's not
there's nothing weird it's just
um i know how my wife kind of operates
and she constantly compares herself to
others and worries about what other
people think
and uh it just seems like she's always
kind of
worried about that or thinking about
that i'm trying to wonder what i could
do to
oh i don't know how to wear that i guess
um
hey can how you well let me let me back
up a little bit so when you say one of
your exes have you been married before
is this an old girlfriend no no no just
a little girlfriend is all about okay
and it's just like a casual a lot of
weight into it like a casual fling old
girlfriend or y'all were pretty serious
oh yeah it was a few rules
do what
it was it lasted a few years okay so
it's pretty serious and how long have
you been married
uh we've only been we're very newly wed
been together about three years okay all
right so your wife has a year on your
old girlfriend in terms of relationship
time
how much longer have you known your
ex-girlfriend than your wife
uh
i guess we went to school together and
everything so quite a while okay
so i'll start right there that's
something that my wife brought up once
that i never ever thought of
which was i'm friends with a lot of my
old exes like i i just liked being
friends with most people i don't see a
reason to
to
burn i just i just like people how about
that and um
it never occurred to me my wife said
some of these people have known you
since you were a small kid and i didn't
know you they will always have five or
10 or 15 relational years on you that
she could never catch up on and i used
to say yeah but we're married like you
won the game is over like there's not a
game anymore
and it never occurred to me that there
was
parts of my life that she would never
get to know that somebody else did
and so i i would start there with a
sense of
your wife is working with this woman who
has way more history with you than she
does
and that's not about looks that's not
about um
like did y'all hook up it's not nothing
like that it's just simply
that person's got more
history with my husband than i do and
that's just heavy right and so anytime
something like that gets called out
before we do good on that road what el
what does she compare herself to looks
uh smarts what is it
um
i kind of just
because my wife is amazing in every way
and i would never would change things
but she uh
it just she don't
she doesn't have the confidence so yeah
i'd say like looks and
um
just i think you you kind of hit home
right there with the time thing that
makes a lot of sense uh i can see that
when she brings up
their stuff and just they're uh
friends on social media but it i think
it's just so kind of keep your friends
close to your enemies closer type thing
i don't think it's
you know what i mean
yeah um
so when you say looks does she think
that your ex is more attractive than she
is
uh i
feel like that's a dangerous one to
answer um no
i'm not asking you if that's the case
i'm asking does she think that does she
say that out loud
uh yeah she's probably feels that way
yeah okay
um does she think that that other woman
is funnier than her or nicer than her or
cooks better or runs faster or is a
better leader i mean what what are the
things be very specific
um i think she thinks that i still
talking to the phone talking on the
phone
i believe that my wife thinks that i
still have uh thoughts about my ex when
i don't and i have a hard time
convincing her of that okay just because
she's always in they're always seeing
each other you know they never get a
break or nothing there's always a
constant reminder of
my old life gotcha okay
so
here's here's an important thing to call
out
um
words and this in this
is this is a hard one to talk your way
through
okay
this is one that you're gonna have to
live your way through
but i do think you start with words on
this one okay
and here's what i mean
have you all sat down and had a direct
not a passive not uh y'all are both
scrolling your phones but a
direct conversation about this
uh yeah a few over the years how how
have they gone not well or fine and then
she just loops back to the way it was
yeah the second one there correct
exactly okay have you ever told her in a
loving way not a mean way not a jerk way
but in a loving way
um
you were the woman i chose to spend the
rest of my life with to get old and die
with
i really don't want to talk about my ex
ever again
have you ever told her that
uh kind of actually i heard that on this
show before okay let's don't do kind of
let's sit down maybe write a letter to
your wife about how wonderful she is and
read it to her here's what i love about
you
i think you're beautiful
and i think you are hilarious and i
think you're really smart and i think
you're going to be a great mom for our
kids one day all
be very specific
and for
often for guy it's hard like it's like
yeah just i love you you know i love you
and then i want you to be very specific
about
what are ways
that i can
through my actions show you
how much i love you
and i know it's the hollywood sells us a
version that we're both to just read
each other's minds
and come up like oh uh
she wants me to do this this this and
this around the house and this and this
and she wants me to exercise
let's get real specific and what i want
you to do is to ask her put her on the
spot say i want to um some things that i
can do
that will show you how much you mean to
me
and i'm going to ask you
one of the ways you can show me that you
love me
is i want to stop ever mentioning that
woman's name in this house
she's not who i picked i picked you
and
if your wife chooses to continually
compare herself to that woman
then at some point you'll have to decide
is that environment good for your
relationship
okay
and that will be hard that would be a
challenge
um but at some point the work
environment is not worth your marriage
but i want you you can't control that
that's her situation your wife's
choosing to do some of the comparative
things i want you to do all of the
things you can do in your power which is
just deal with your thoughts and with
your actions and so be very specific
with her about what how much you care
about and what you love and then be very
specific about asking for
what are some very specific things you
hear me say very specific over and over
again what are some things i can do
around here
that not to show you that i love you
more than her not to show you that i'm
over her
but that i can love you better how can i
do that i want you to be real
intentional and direct about that stuff
and this is gonna take two months five
months six months ten months and let's
go ahead and call out
i understand
clearly
that this woman knew me when i was in
middle school in high school there's
parts of me that she got to see that you
never got to see and let's just thank
god
she got to see me with lots of zits she
got to see me with acting like an idiot
on the bus you get to see all that
and
i'm so glad that you didn't have to know
that that guy because
modern bill is way is a better human
being right so i'm glad but i also know
that's hard and um i i honor that that's
hard
but here's how much i love you now let's
start there and give that a shot we'll
be right back
my friends family co-workers they all
make fun of me because i'm a cheapskate
i borrow stuff i don't like spending
money except on a few high quality items
i like buying things that work and that
last and that keep me safe and keep me
well like shoes tires and most
importantly
mattresses sleep is the cornerstone of
everything sleep helps me make good diet
choices relational choices it helps me
be a better writer father husband and
co-worker everything starts or stops
with sleep and as we all know sleep
begins with a world-class mattress and
what now there's a great mattress that
doesn't cost a million bucks you got my
attention and that's why i've partnered
with dream cloud mattress they figured
it out they're running their biggest
offer ever for you dr john daloni show
listeners 399 bucks in accessories plus
an additional 250 bucks in cash discount
that's a total of almost 650 dollars in
total savings pillows mattress
protectors sheets all of it visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney and get your mattress and
savings today
we are
back
[Music]
is that a song by the killers no i just
made that up billy joel maybe all right
let's go to lynn and i could see
everybody's been like how about you stop
talking to looney i will stop talking
let's go to lynn in omaha what's up lind
hi
what's up
it's good it's monday
are you awake
i am well into my coffee oh he said like
you're well into a few margaritas are
you doing good
all right guys
all right so what's up how can i help
um so
i know that you have
quite the background with first
responders
um and i am an intern therapist that's
going to start working with first
responders in my town and so i was just
looking for
um
some advice about
just how to like empower them to break
the stigma of talking about their mental
health
very cool so how did you get how did you
get hooked up with wanting to work with
first responders
um so the office that i'm interning at
they actually have a contract with our
first responders so they do
just yearly like mental health check-ins
but
as i'm coming on i'm gonna work more
with them i'll be at the station
very cool oh you're gonna be embedded
you're gonna be in are you talking about
police officers ems firefighters who who
are you working with
um firefighters
okay wow
that is incredible very cool and so
you're gonna be actually at the station
and they can come in and see you anytime
yes wow okay
so
man number one good for you for asking
um before we dig into some of my
thoughts on this have you gone to the
station yet have you have you actually
sat with clients yet
um not at the fire station my first week
will be next week have you met with
clients back at home
i mean back in uh back in the office
yes and how how is that going
um it's good
it's
obviously everybody's nervous when you
first start but yeah i think it's gone
well i've been
in the mental health field for about 10
years okay i'm just oh
so when they
are they open to you do they talk or do
they just say yes ma'am yes ma'am yes
ma'am and then
check their box and get out
and now they
they open up yeah
so what are you worried about
um well it's just i feel like it's just
like breaking the stigma of talking
about their mental health because i feel
like those first responders it might be
different because
they're kind of put on this pedestal of
well you run into a burning building
while we're all running out
you know like a real life superhero and
so
i've just watched a lot of things on how
they struggle with that and the high
rates of suicide
because they don't talk about it as much
because
the perception the rest of the community
kind of holds of
first responders is so high that they
maybe bury it more than other people so
it's actually been my experience that
the stigma comes internally
and some of the stigma that that happens
internally in the culture of a fire
department the culture of a police
department
is actually really true and honest i get
it and here's what i mean
if
it comes out
if it was
made public that i'm struggling with
depression there's a chance they take
you off the beat
they don't let you be a police officer
they won't let you go
you'll be stuck in the firehouse doing
chores they won't let you out
um to go fight fires to go show up at a
car wreck where you're trained and
you're skilled
if you're talking about having
nightmares or you're anxious or you're
having a little bit of ptsd
after an incident they may put you
behind a desk
they may take your badge away from you
they may medically retire you so there's
some true and real consequences to
saying some of that stuff out loud
and so
the perception sometimes in the
community it is oh those guys just won't
talk
it's because they can't literally they
can't they might lose their job or
that's the perception right and in some
some units that's very very true
um that's why i'm both really excited
and shocked that they're put they're
embedding you in um
in a firehouse because that means
someone's gonna come in to talk to you
and their peers are gonna watch them go
in and talk to you
that tells me that you're entering into
a
remarkable
firehouse a who's got a chief that
really understands care and really wants
his people to be well
and just because you're not doing well
in a season doesn't mean that you can't
do it forever or just because you're
struggling here doesn't mean you're not
a great asset to us so i think number
one is recognizing that there are some
very real costs to
um
to having some mental health challenges
to having some physical health
challenges so what does that mean for
you
that means being super super transparent
about what you're writing down
what you're not writing down be very
very clear with your supervisor and with
the chief about how you have to do or
not do diagnostics
meaning if you can avoid say
any sort of
this person has anxiety disorder or this
person's got depressive disorder if you
can avoid that
then you're gonna earn a lot of trust if
it's written down somewhere that such
and such person is struggling with such
and such diagnosis
then they're going to have a heart
because that's going to show up in a
performance review potentially right
unless they are very clear about
separating the two and if they do oh
that's incredible man because that's
really encouraging people to get the
help they need um the second thing is
is yes there's a there's that perception
but
i have found that there is very little
that can stand between a therapist and a
police officer a fire environment a
nurse like lived experience
and so my recommendation to anybody
working with that that population
um ask to go on ride-alongs
ask to can i ride in the car and police
officers have programs that let you do
that i'm not certain about fire
firefighters i don't know the safety of
that but
ask if you can go on ride-alongs and you
may have to do it on your weekends off
it may maybe in the evenings or in the
middle of the night that's when i did it
i did it 24 7. it was all hours of the
day but usually it was in the middle of
the night
um and what you will find is they and
over time this is gonna take a while you
can't just do this twice and it's good
they will see you as somebody they trust
because they see you shoulder to
shoulder with him or even just in the
vicinity of them
and they may say no you can't come along
no you can't come along no you can't
come along keep asking
keep asking keep asking and i'll tell
you this if you do go on some of these
rides if you do
have an opportunity to join like a
victim services group or some sort of
victims advocacy group
um
that will help if you choose to not work
with first responders that will still
help any and every mental health
practice you ever go into for the rest
of your career
having being able to sit with hurting
people in their
rawest moment of crisis is a gift it's
an honorable it's a holy moment it's a
special time and so go do that will help
you become a better therapist that would
help you become a better parent a better
human okay so i would ask if you can
participate in some of that stuff and
then here's my third piece of advice
um
have you ever had like a major surgery
i feel a few okay let's pretend you had
you uh you needed a liver transplant
would you only get surgery from a
surgeon who's had a liver transplant
themselves or do you just want the best
surgeon the best surgeon there you go
often
counselors
mental health professionals you know
licensed social workers we limit
ourselves
we think that we're not enough because
we've never been a firefighter i've
never been a police officer and so a
friend of mine she worked she was a
military veteran um dr martin she's
incredible name's erin she gave me a
great line because i was i was meeting
with veterans and i kept saying i kept
limiting myself saying i've never been
to combat overseas i don't know what
that's like
and the line she gave me was to say
if someone says you don't know what it's
like then you lean in and you say
and i can only know what you've been
through if you'll tell me
oh i can only understand what you've
been through even a little bit if you'll
paint me a picture or walk me through a
day in the life of
and that gives them an avenue that gives
them permission because now they're
teaching you and all of us like to teach
other people and so if you can not limit
yourself
don't go in like kind of peering down
like i don't really know what you're
going through
walk in and say i'm going to be the best
therapist in the world for this group of
people i love them i'm gonna do my best
to find ways that i can not walk in
their shoes but walk next to them walk
next to their shoes but i'm gonna hold
my head up high i'm gonna become the
best therapist and just because i've
never
had brain surgery doesn't mean i can't
be a great brain surgeon okay just
because no one's shot at you you've
never jumped out of a
out of a third story window with you
know with a cat or whatever the thing is
you've never run into a burning building
doesn't mean that you can't learn the
skills to really be good at this
uh i'll throw one fourth thing in okay
watch as little tv as possible
what hap the the the pictures we get of
first responders from tv is often
shenanigans it's not real it's just
stupid
um it's very very different than the day
in day out grind that we see happen to
our first responders of the day and the
day and the night and the night over and
over it's very different than
some super good looking
i mean there's some there's some smoke
show firefighters let's make it let's be
clear about that but then some
good-looking hollywood actor you know
coming out and being like oh look you
know all flexed and oiled up and
whatever um so i would watch as little
tv as possible watch the office watch
you know shit's creek watch funny shows
don't watch you know law and order svu
thinking you're going to learn something
that's going to help you does that make
sense
yeah awesome so does that help
it did thank you awesome hey can i just
tell you i'm really grateful for you we
need more people with your heart who's
willing to go it's a tough tough
community to serve
um from
in a mental health capacity
first responders are tough they see hard
stuff they do hard stuff they know all
the answers that you're supposed to say
and they have some very real
professional ramifications if they get
in trouble
or if they are perceived to have mental
health issues if you on them i'm making
the air quotes on issues
so we need more people to get right in
the middle of that and i'm really really
grateful that you're choosing to do that
thank you for doing that on behalf of
our communities thank you thank you
thank you all right um hey uh everybody
we'll be right back
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to
greensbury.com and you'll get 10 off
your first purchase check it out today
your nutrition is worth it
all right we are back let's go to san
antonio and hi felicia what's up
hello
what are you up to
i'm at work but you know took a break
very very cool way to go
hey yeah so felicia is like my top three
favorite names of all time ever in the
history of the world so thank you for
having that name on my show today all
right so what's up
so i my question for you is so my
husband um
comes from a very religious family
um
was kind of like
you know was kicked out
of his family kind of brought back in
he's starting therapy and he will be
doing trauma therapy
and i
probably walk that line where i ask too
many questions okay
so i'm trying to find like where is that
balance
uh
whoo so you
you just mentioned a lot so
is the trauma therapy because of
religious abuse or is it because of
sexual and physical abuse why is he
seeking trauma therapy and what does
that have to do with his
uber religious upbringing
so um
yes he's
one of four
his um his the oldest is his sister who
is like they've told him
she's the star child she is the favorite
her grandkids
are everything and then he has a
then it's him jared
and then um
it's his
second younger brother who is autistic
and schizophrenic and then his baby
brother and um
basically his sister ratted him out
um to get back into mom and dad's good
graces when he was like 21.
what did he do
he drank alcohol and got a tattoo
i know he's wild felicia
you are calling the wrong show honey
i got a lot of tattoos actually so
like oh no you're good um okay so that
guy so
having a beer and having a tattoo got
him in trouble with his with his family
yes they kicked him out don't call don't
write don't text
don't do any of that um
he
tried to commit suicide
and
then it was like oh wait
we kind of love you but because you
don't
subscribe
you're still on the outside so i think
he was never like hit
or it's like sexually physically abused
but i think they're well i know there's
a lot of like emotional absolutely yes
neglect kind of
he was always the odd one out okay um
yeah i mean even now
yeah
and it doesn't help that they live like
10 minutes away yeah yeah um so i'm
gonna tell you this up front okay
a cornerstone of his trauma therapy is
going to be
cutting ties with his family for a
season if not forever
and something tells me that that's going
to be very challenging for him for you
and for your family unit
um
similar you can't um
you can't heal from addiction
if all of your friends still deal drugs
and you all share a house
or they all live 10 minutes away from
you
and so i want you to think of
trauma as it's not don't think of it as
the definition of trauma is
a series of things that happened that
overwhelm our body's response system
right it's like a tsunami it overwhelms
it
and
that usually comes in the not in the
form of these stories but it comes in
the form of our body remembering these
things it remembers the time the bear
attacked us
and chewed us up and we got away
and where trauma is really
it's impossible to heal from
when the bear keeps coming over to the
living room when the bear keeps coming
over and coming over and coming over so
these same people that heard him told
him
really destructive misguided things
about what love looks like
love looks like get out of our lives if
you have a drink and a tattoo love looks
like god hates you love looks like you
do life like us or we hate you
that's that has wreaked havoc
on a well-functioning body on a
well-functioning psyche right
and so you're gonna have to at some
point break ties with that with that
crew for a while
something tells me that
he's still pretty entangled there um i
would
i would be surprised if them quote
unquote disowning him was the
the sole reason he tried to take his
life what was what was his suicide about
yeah it was right after that um
yeah
he was
like
he was very sheltered so like taking
care of himself was like
he didn't know how to balance a
checkbook he didn't know he didn't know
like these basic things how to change
his oil when to change his oil and i
think
when i've talked to him about it it just
all became too much
and the fact that his parents just it
was like a little bit over a year after
they kicked him out
so they never allowed him to breathe and
all of a sudden they ripped away the
oxygen
and he
was never able to get his feet
underneath him and he just wanted that
to stop that hurt to stop okay
um
so
how do you factor into this are y'all
are married right
yes two years march 12th okay and um how
do you get along with his mom and dad
his sister i don't you don't okay cool
so
my parents um
live in san antonio also okay and
they've like really
just
accepted him loved him like we spend
most of our holidays with them
but there's
just this
he can't
he's very guarded of his family sure
absolutely and so what i want you to
um it's gonna be hard for you because
for you
that's not your family that's a couple
of people a couple of three or four
people that continually hurt your
husband
right
like they are evil to you because they
continually
beat up on your husband whether
psychologically you know what i mean and
so i want you to
be from this day forward don't say
another negative thing about them okay
at least for us until he's well until he
can be he can open be open about it okay
um you can tell him when he says hey i
need to go see mom and dad you can say
um
[Music]
are you doing well
is that a good idea for you today it's
not about them why would you go do that
they're the word nope it is i love you
and are you is that wise for you same as
my wife when i am at the drive-through
of some
trashy establishment and i say
i would like a number
one with extra and she'll stop me to go
is that a wise choice right now
you know what i mean she's not saying
like you
she's just giving me one extra chance to
think about it right and sometimes i'm
like yeah you're right i'm an idiot and
i'll just say never mind can i have a
cup of coffee and then sometimes i'm
like yep i'm crashing into that brick
wall dude right
so let's lean more towards him okay and
this is gonna be really hard for you and
i want you to make sure you hear what
i'm saying okay
don't take his healing as he enters
counseling don't take his healing as a
sign that he can't trust you
don't take his
um silence or his unwillingness to talk
about stuff at the beginning
as a sign there's something wrong with
you or your relationship it's really
easy to take that sort of silence
personally
and right now as he goes into surgery
which is what trauma counseling is
um you wouldn't ask his surgeon who's
giving him knee surgery to go ahead and
cut your knees up too just because
this is his surgery and he needs you to
care for him when he gets out
and also make sure that he's got a safe
place to talk if and when he's ready
this means one important thing you have
to have somebody to talk to because it
might not be him for a season
okay do you have that
i do i recommend everybody who has a
spouse going to trauma counseling that
they go to some form of counseling or
have a close group of friends or one or
two people they meet with every single
week
because it's gonna feel really lonely
for a season
just for a season it's gonna feel really
lonely okay
so don't beat him up about not talking
to you don't take it personally
and
i would really you hear me say this all
the time on the show and i know it's
like a broken record
give him a place to write
down things
whether you start to get a journal and
say as you enter this i want you to know
that i love you he's not going to always
be able to hear you but i want you to
write him notes and you leave that on
his pillow
and then he can write you back and leave
it on your pillow it will just be a back
and forth
um journal that you'll write together a
diary all right back and forth together
um a letter writing y'all right back and
forth together and this will be a
monument to your to both of your healing
over the next however many years okay
okay things in that journal will be like
i see you today
i want you to know that you're loved
your hug today allowed me to breathe a
little bit deeper
i know how hard you're working
or i miss you
you are absent today and i know that
you're somewhere hard and i want you to
know that i'm here and i love you that's
what i'm talking about in this thing
okay
i had a funny memory of you today that
when we first started dating this
happened and it reminded me why i love
you so much
this isn't all pollyanna and all
positive it could be some dark stuff too
but i want him to not be able to here's
what people with trauma are good at
absorbing the good and dismissing it and
just scanning the environment for the
bad for the bad for the bad for the bad
because they've had to
he's waiting for you to leave him also
for him to do the one wrong thing that's
gonna kick it's gonna
make you hit the highway
if you write it down
he can't run from it he will see it over
and over and over again hear what i'm
saying
yeah this becomes a critical thing um
when does he start going to counseling
next week next week is the first big one
okay um does he want you to go with him
or does he want to do this by himself
um we've talked about like every now and
then maybe like a
joint like a you know the both of us
going
but
for now it's just he wants to do it okay
i think if you get your own counselor
during the season two
after three four five weeks you invite
him to your session
and say i'd love for you to come visit
me
and that might be a session where you
can talk y'all can start learning new
languages as you're as you're moving
along here
he's gonna remember stuff that he hasn't
remembered in a long time he's gonna
walk this will be a hard season for both
of you
commit to staying anchored to him okay
okay do you promise
oh yeah i can do that i mean i just
don't understand
like
the world is the worst place without him
so yeah there you go that's a and he
needs to hear you say that needs to read
you say that he needs to feel you
believe that
and that can be 30 second hugs to start
every day even this morning as i was
running out of the house my wife said i
haven't got my hug yet
and that wasn't her hug the hug was for
me
and so i stopped put everything down and
we got our 30 second hug in this morning
okay that's her making sure she didn't
say hey you look scattered today you
look like you're all over the place
again um what's going on overseas has
really done a number on me that that she
didn't bring up any of that stuff
you want to talk about it what are you
worried about she didn't do any of that
stuff she just said i didn't get my hug
this morning
and i stopped and realized okay i know
what she's telling me i need to put my
phone down i need to stop scrolling i
need to i need to i need right so come
up with that with your language together
that way remind him that he's anchored
into you and y'all are anchored into
stone you're not going anywhere okay
um my promise to you is this
if he goes through this
you go through it and you'll do this
together as best you can
there is a big
beautiful future on the back end of this
for y'all
this is legacy change this is changing
family trees this is him having the
courage to stand up and say i will not
put my kids through this i will not put
my wife through this i will not put me
through this anymore
this is owning what comes next hey hang
on the line here i'm going to send you
guys a copy of my new book own your past
change your future y'all can read this
together
it's going to parallel his journey it's
going to give you all some things to
talk about together
and you can read a chapter you can read
it together you can read it he can read
it and
then you can say what do you think about
that chapter it gives you an entry point
into a conversation or he might say that
chapter's full of crap or he might say
you should go read chapter this because
that one really spoke to me
and then it gives you all some play by
play on what to do on the back end of
this deal
i'm excited for this journey all about
to go on it is going to be hard
don't take it personal but stay
connected god he's lucky to have you
felicia
and so
as the great cube once said
bye felicia we'll be right back
big secret almost all of us can control
our thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them
most people believe thoughts randomly
happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be so go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back hey uh before we
go further
kelly
listen
of all like you're one of my closest
friends here and i give you hell every
time on the show
what most people listening to the show
do not understand is the depth and the
amount of emails that you go through of
people's
gut-wrenching pain
and we got a couple in recently about
some really gnarly child abuse that was
in progress that's happening
and that have just some ugliness and so
on behalf of everybody you don't get
enough credit for this you don't get any
credit for this
it's important to stop and just say
thank you for this this is
hard hard hard
the one you sent me the other night i
got viscerally
you read my response i was
and you read that all
day so
for all like the i get all the emails
and the the uh social medias talking
about all these people that thank you
for your help thank you for help none of
that happens without you and so i'm
grateful for you that's hard what you do
is hard so thank you
now we'll go back to i'm just kidding
i'm just gonna it's i'm not it's just
you're you're the stud dude it's so
incredible what you have to wade through
every week man
and husband's good
yeah his surgery went well yes he had
ankle surgery it was but it went well
yeah he's doing good all right good
awesome and you got some percocet i'm
just kidding no no no no listen
absolutely not as we wrap up today's
show oh man when inside jokes go outside
they don't sound right at all right
song is by uh i love this group the
killers yet again there you go zach he's
not even here but shout out zach
so i called all these things i've done
it goes like this when there's nowhere
else to run is there room for one more
son
one more son
if you can hold on if you can hold on i
want to stand up i want to let go you
know you know no you don't you don't i
want to shine on in the hearts of man i
want a meaning from the back of my
broken hand another headaches another
heart breaks and i'm so much older than
i can take and my affection will it
comes and goes i need direction to
perfection
no
help me out
yeah you know you gotta help me out
that's what we're here for we'll see you
soon